for the past three years jubilee has
been working on a feature-length
documentary
and it's just been announced that we'll
be premiering at
tribeca film festival the film is called
accepted
it's a about a small school in rural
louisiana
that became famous for sending most of
its students to ivy league schools and
we follow four students through our
senior year what ends up becoming a
really crazy tumultuous
and challenging senior year and we
cannot wait for you to see it
follow accepted film everywhere and
acceptedfilm.com to learn more
but i just want to take a moment to say
thank you thank you for being with
me and with our team throughout this
journey and we can't wait
to not only bring you our content here
online
but now bring you empathy fueled content
in film and in television as well
so more to come stay tuned but we love
you
thank you
wait let's get to the juicy ones have
you guys ever cheated no
okay same
[Music]
uh we can start i'm jules i'm izzy um
we've been dating for
15 months 16 months yeah and i'm a phd
student
in i study renewable energy i work in
mental health care
and we met on hinge yeah we've been
dating for a little over two years
we just kind of met through friends like
all of our friends knew each other but
we just never met
and then we met one day and yeah i'm
from norway i'm a photographer
i'm an actor writer entrepreneur we met
in berlin
on tinder yeah we met on tinder much
like you guys
and we did long distance for four years
in college uh we've been going out for
five years
the fact that we clicked so well was you
know almost surprised again i feel like
over the past
five years of our relationship i've just
been thinking about what what does
compatibility truly mean
for us it just means that we have the
same views and values
similar interests how do you resolve
problems
how do you communicate how do you like
adjust to each other
like in different situations values
and shared interests were the two main
things um and the sort of goals we have
and where we see our lives going
how was it having a long distance
relationship guys um
challenging yeah i think so we had met
only five months before
um you know we started long distance so
we kind of had to think like
did we want to hold each other back in
college but then like the
weeks ticked down and until it was
finally time to like you know our plan
breakup but then we just couldn't hold
ourselves to do it and
we just ended up sticking together and
it worked out and now we're living
together
yeah five years later here we are just
their story of
staying together committed long distance
all throughout college like we did it
for
a year and a half and like it's hard
when you guys met
you said in berlin were you like
studying there were you just traveling
there like how did that
i was studying abroad for a year i asked
some friends of mine like what are you
going to do this weekend and they were
just like we're going to berlin do you
want to come
i don't know they had their own plans i
was kind of like checking on tinder see
if
anyone was cute there and i met this guy
daniel noah's story i liked their story
it was like a fairy tale almost
it seemed like they were like meant to
be together so is this your first
serious relationship i think that's like
important to note not because it means
that it like won't be your
your relationship but also i think that
like a lot of understanding
compatibility comes with like having
experiences before that like maybe
weren't as good so like
it gives a lot of confidence and
compatibility if you have had
incompatible
relationships before i would just
counter that on the note that like just
because i hadn't been in a serious
relationship doesn't mean that i haven't
been
dating and dating many different people
and having my experiences and learning
what it means for me personally to find
the one that i want to call mine
when other people were bringing up the
fact that i hadn't been in other
relationships
as like maybe a reason why like we're
less compatible
i just know in my heart that you're the
one for me
i mean we met like right after i
graduated high school and she was
a senior so i felt like that was like
not challenging but it was just
different to be like
in a committed relationship like so
young when most people like all my
friends were all single
and i was like the only one i definitely
could see why people because we're so
young
there is that like stereotype that we
still have so much
that we need to experience in life i
also know us
and i know how we are and i know how we
interact it's really hard because
you know i i don't want to fault you
guys obviously for not having more time
you know what i mean yeah like no matter
what i feel like
time and you guys obviously all seem
like amazing couples
you know what i mean and especially like
as queer people like we we
need time to like come to our terms with
ourselves and you know
take the step of dating each other i
feel like you guys are one just like
it's like a majority of like components
one you have like time
you have distance you have like living
together
your plans for the future so you guys
need to move up there
[Music]
okay i think bradley and eric were
clearly very compatible
i want to say that we were the most
because i mean we know us
because everybody wants to be the first
and i think everyone has a right to rank
themselves first
if any of you think there should be
number one you can understand
where they're standing like behind them
or something
[Music]
they're number two technically now
i think we should be higher but that's
just my opinion
i agree i feel that we have that other
aspect to it that we were talking about
like the guys
on the first place here have like we
like share a lot of the same things
there
i would maybe argue like putting us in
second but
i'm also like i don't know i feel like i
don't know i feel like
in between you guys i honestly feel like
really strongly for both you guys
number two you know what i mean because
i feel like you guys have such a strong
relationship
and you've lived together and you've
like built that bond
at the end of the day it came down to
lived experience
the the younger couple hadn't been
together quite as long and
i feel bad about that honestly looking
back at it i almost feel bad i feel like
just because we haven't been to
through like hardships that makes uh
you guys put us and forth i'm honestly
fine for whatever because i know that
all of us are compatible
i'm gonna say i'm happy where i am i
think sure
fine with whatever were you satisfied
with
yes and no the end of the day like it's
subjective and
we thought that all of the other couples
were like
cute and they went well together so
i know that we are compatible so i'm
like oh i wish other people can see that
but there's only so much that you can
like show people
without showing them everything
[Music]
i think the basic elements of what
humans want in a relationship
is probably the same love comfortability
honesty respect of course the dynamics
are going to be different
and the obstacles that we face as
couples are going to be different
at the end of the day i feel like we're
all just people who are looking for love
who you know hopefully find their mate
someone that they're super crazy about
who's crazy about them
i think most people use interests
and values and goals and the way that
you feel when you're with them too
so i don't see how that would really
differ with the same-sex couple
converted a straight couple
i will say though for this couple i feel
like their personalities and their
temperaments really complement each
other couple number two
i feel like they're a little more
compatible she's going through a phd
program and they're making it work
so i kind of want to sort of give like
the dark horse nod to them for number
one
and give them number two couple number
three
i remember he said something how he had
dated before
he always felt how do you know when
you're with the one and then with him he
felt it immediately anew
and i think i just like see that in them
and that's why i would rank three higher
i think three should be ranked higher i
can just tell even from their physical
presence
they're very comfortable with one
another should we move them
should we move three to two
does anybody want to express where four
should stand should they say number four
or should should
babies run there's still like a lot they
haven't done yet together
when i was younger like those were some
of the most like open
passionate like huge relationships
because you're so
you're so raw and i'm so conflicted
because i feel like
they give each other so much and when
you give each other so much you're going
to be more
compatible i think still for me there's
just so many unknowns in terms of their
compatibility
partly because of age and life
experience and stuff like that
i don't know if it really fully makes
sense to just assume that they will have
trouble because they haven't been
together longer
oh definitely yeah we're not assuming
that they're gonna no no i'm not saying
but like it's kind of just like
you know that's almost like the
arguments you're like well you don't
know things so they might not be
compatible
so i guess this is it raise of hands to
keep this line up one two three
[Music]
regardless of the metrics that we use to
come to this conclusion
like we would have been happy and fourth
place too because it's subjective
and arguably like these are all amazing
couples and
i was really really moved by all of your
guys's stories and i'm so happy that you
guys are happy
and i i wish the best for all of us same
to you guys totally
it's like hard to really say who is
more compatible than the other person
when we only have so much time to get to
know them
there's so many things to consider it's
kind of like hard to like put someone
there and there and there
i feel like looking at all those couples
today just really really affirmed in my
heart that i made the right choice
i love you and this was really fun thank
you so much for
being willing to grow with me and i'm so
glad that i found somebody that i'm
so so compatible with
[Music]
you